it's been a remarkable year for climate
change reports rebellions protests I
care about climate justice and the
Living Planet and then a big bonus we
will be ending our contribution to
climate change by 2050 and legislating
for a net zero emissions target but for
those tasked with monitoring our
progress it's a promise
we can't currently keep we're not even
on track to meet the original less
ambitious targets very helpfully we've
set a new target
that's Greed's but it's not some magical
fix you need to have a set of deep
policies in each of the sectors that
engage real people in fact last year the
Committee on Climate Change made 25
policy recommendations only one has been
delivered 10 have not even seen partial
progress while there have been successes
the power industry for example has moved
away from coal and embraced a boom in
offshore wind emissions from sectors
like buildings have flatlined while an
aviation and transport they've increased
new policy is needed in the next 18
months if the targets are to be reached
petrol and diesel cars will need to be
phased out ideally by 2030 we'll need
carbon capture technology no more gas
boilers and new buildings we'll all need
to look like this South London
development well you can see just how
thick the walls are look at that and
also the windows are triple glazed and
we've also got solar panels on the
windows which generate some electricity
the savings for the people that live in
them really sort of speak for themselves
I mean pure bills are really low also
they're very attractive to sell so
sustainable eco homes like this also
tell to sell quite quickly so that's
quite an attractive thing for developers
there are plenty of examples to show
that a low-carbon existence is not just
possible but achievable the technology
does exist but the wrap of this report
is that there just isn't the policy to
make change happen in short there's a
goal and a means but just no plan and
time is running out
a government spokesman said we know
there's more to do and legislating for
NetZero will help to drive further
action will set up plans in the coming
months to tackle emissions from aviation
heat energy agriculture and transport of
course all this will cost money and it
won't necessarily be a vote winner will
the next Prime Minister translate this
year of pressure into policy Helen Anne
Smith Sky News